- Ground reaction force
data, joint kinematics,
underfoot pressure, thermal
cameras, high speed video.
The bridge between data and
performance is really that with
the right information we
can make better decisions.
(intense music)
Hi I'm Keith Stern and I
use data to help athletes
break records.
At the top level runners,
there's only a few seconds
between the person that finishes first
and the person that doesn't
podium finish at all.
So any small change can
really make a big impact
down the road.
My job here is to work
with the rest of the Reebok
Innovation Team to help bring
data into the design process.
- Hi, my name's Dan Hobson,
I'm the VP of Innovation.
There's a lot of information
to take into consideration.
On campus here, we built a
crossfit box and lived with
the athletes, monitoring
how they were working out,
what they were eating,
how they were recovering
and making that understandable
for the design team.
Keith Stern is testing the product,
he's gathering data.
The amount of data he can
compile with his team is vast.
- A lot of our testing
on athletes starts here
in the human performance engineering lab.
The force plate treadmill is
actually a split belt treadmill
so that we can record forces
from the left and right foot.
(intense music)
The mechanical impacting
machine simulates what we see in
ground reaction force data and
then look at the performance
of the material over time.
Through high speed video we
can track how much your foot
is moving in certain areas.
A lot of the times we can't
see with the naked eye
what's going on in those
really fast movements.
So slowing it down, the transfer
of knowledge is way easier
than graphs and charts and numbers.
It's really easy to understand:
how the shoe works with
that person can make a big
difference in their running form.
(footsteps)
Future of data collection
in athletic performance is
something that's really important.
There's a growing field of smart sensors,
sensors could be woven
into this technology that
we're developing with Flexweave.
Flexweave is really a method
a weaving materials together
and allows us to combine
structure, durability,
into a single package that's
also still lightweight
and breathable.
The same types of things
that we record in the lab
we can then record on foot in the field.
- So if you have those smart
fibers in the Flexweave,
if you wanna track heart rate
or distance or put GPS in it
you know into those fibers
you can weave that into
the fabric.
- The more data we have the
better we can make decisions on
what types of material
advances are actually making
an improvement.
Providing that performance
benefit, even if it's just comfort
to get people up and
active, that's what really
important to me.
(gentle music)